ladies and gentlemen are you ready for
the most intense hardcore gaining
journalism on the internet right now
round of applause audience let's go
everybody's ready let's go it's exciting
hey everybody uh welcome on out careful
you're gonna hit too hard hurting all
right today it hurts
yeah the journalism hurts me it's hard
hitting hard it's so hard hitting then
it is very hard-hitting journalist yeah
it's crazy
uh everybody welcome out to the GameSpot
co-op stage game attack is here along
with this superstar of the internet
Brandon Jones
uneasy allies the highest the biggest
patreon in history
Brandon Joel like with easier oh sorry
mr. alright
and there's Sam Mitchell from screw
attack and that's on this special we're
gonna do all right school ok so today
we're talking about e3 we're here on
this flight
huh why are we talking about e3 uh it's
just your chance we can talk about
anything
yeah all of all the chances here's your
soapbox yeah so we got about thirty
minutes before we do our first first
stage demo here and by that we'll have
ladies with fire on stage coming up so
make sure you don't go anywhere it's
gonna be great belly dancers belly
dancers tossing fired rings in this in
the sky landing on Brandon Jones Oh
it'll be good yeah you didn't know that
we won't put him out even stick around
after that absolutely yeah it's gonna
because you're dead body right sorry
they're on this let's talk let's talk
the let's let's get to the important
journalism side of things because we all
know that we are all important
journalists okay okay so let's talk
about the things were most excited about
out of all the announcements that have
happened over the last couple days let's
start with you Sam okay so I remember
earlier I told you a couple things yeah
gotten him my point of view has changed
but did you I won't tell you what you
said no I have a list right here I'm
gonna go I'm gonna start with anthem
because I think what you said okay you
know I'm just starting somewhere good
talk about anthem because it looks like
it could be everything I wanted from
destiny but not destiny which is a good
thing so you know I'm excited look it
looks really pretty look at it it's like
I know you rock it's hearing through
everything like how many all remember
the movie the
Rocketeer anybody raise your hand if you
remember the rock out here yeah rockets
here we go Marlon microphone guy right
there everybody get Marlon round of
applause ever round of applause for
Marlon back there alright Mike it was
Marlon right so the Rockets here was
this uh this there's only cares look
it's got aliens no one cares about
Rocketeer starring whatever his name was
and one who's the who's the actress
might one love Jennifer Connelly well
she's so good uh yeah like it looks like
post-apocalyptic iron man meets a ball
yeah do you really need anything else
like look you don't know water the
waters it is with what with with such a
lames underwater flames under water out
the tail out
no now they're just jet boosters but
well how does it know if you have a
smart jet pack yeah I love it
yeah it looks pretty good though it's
fun I'm scared I'm scared like for me
this looks like a lot of opportunities
for like microtransactions and like
nickel and diamond so like it's there
yeah I'm gonna have to just like watch I
think it's like the best looking game
like of the show probably in my opinion
but like I just feel like with power
suits and components and yeah ain't jobs
and weapons and rarities it's like it
has the highest ability to be great and
terrible at the same time yeah yeah yeah
it could really go either way which is
I'm excited about it's a big dice roll
on it look at we can we all agree though
that we are in the golden age of
particle effects when it comes to
explosions and crampons look at his jet
boosters she's just he's just running
around he's not even boosting it's just
it just happens on him how many times do
you think they tried to get that angle
where he was running and not looking
straight just like hit a tree or so
that's actually yes that's actually my
dream job is to be the guy that records
the gameplays yeah we bore these you
know this man you're walking really slow
like in a first-person shooter and like
you never play a game where you just do
this you have my joonyoung actually I do
cinematography mode wait for seven yeah
so Bolin what about you dude what what's
the game that you're really looking for
your biggest win so far y'all gonna love
this the crew - right
that's okay like a hell yeah for the
crew to come on than anybody know nobody
I right there yeah they really got even
say hell
yeah now the creature two syllables I'd
say the crew too and also days gone I
feel like I feel like nobody's really
he's excited about days gone
er thank you so much like the zombies
move so fast and like in flocks and like
no other game is really doing that and
like I don't know just in I mean or you
know they don't move in flocks and Call
of Duty
like they move in flocks absolutely they
move in flop so we look for task box
yeah yeah not they don't swarm people
like I'm not waiting izing them yeah
yeah yeah like I saw they become like
one amorphous mass that comes at you
yeah they just wash over like World War
Z there was a we saw this thing that
wasn't like in the demo but um Sam we we
saw something today like in their booth
where this like a random bad guy Raider
dude was like taunting the zombie that
was like chained to a tree or whatever
yeah and the player just like like shot
a bolt at the chain and it came off of
the tree and the zombie just like
totally like ate the stutes face off
yeah
it looks as though water I mean zombies
like become a big ball of water it's
sweet yeah my most hype game of the
years crash insane trilogy like I'm just
gonna like I'm just getting this right
there
I don't know if y'all are subscribed to
game attack but you should be because on
June 30th at 11:00 a.m. I'm gonna put
that mother in that ps4 and we're gonna
stream it until it is done you hear the
news today boy what's that morning well
sister is playable in all three games
what breaking news bones about Devin
aneurysm here it is so you mean that's
double the crash insanity double the
crash insanity she's got a run runs
around her little laptop it's gonna be a
great summer it's gonna be a great so
give me a great 12 hours yeah you're
just gonna sit down and go from 6 to C
and then I'm gonna go home and
hundred-percent it like six times
good what about you Brandon spider-man
really oh yeah spider-man ah the game
this is so this is a long time coming
for me like ever since my first time
spider-man 2 on ps2 I'm like there's no
way that game is what I think it is then
I played it I'm like yeah they did it is
amazing yeah and then every spider-man
game since it's like we're gonna do
something different now that would
time-travel now there's multiple
spider-man now there's always like a
there's like trick to it sure sure sure
it's just called spider-man they're like
no it's not tied to a movie so you get
that our competence Alif just like we
can you know do our own designs of the
villains we can
you know have like villains working
together we can bring in the Fantastic
Four other Marvel people if we want I
just think there's so much potential in
this game how many all are excited for
spider-man the guy you gotta go to there
we go there we go are you ready for the
for the wet the wet blanket of e3 are
you ready for this because bones about
to be the well you know go ahead Boland
tell him why I'm not excited okay I got
you back animate on it what spider-man
on ps2 was like it was awesome yeah all
right I played it I played that while
listening to like drowning pool like it
was like total juxtaposition like total
like whatever great I was in like hours
at a time and like this looks awesome
until like this is 2017 right I should
I shouldn't have to watch who I'm
controlling run up a crane as it's
falling like I should be spider-man I
hear you well Green is a - that moment
though because that is definitely a
spider-man moment to have a very large
object that he has to stop from you know
killing lots of course I'm just saying
like I would like to see some kind of
physics system where you have to rot
wrap around it seriously and use the web
you know I'm very much over I have a
button the the QuickTime events
everything yeah everything that you just
saw in the gameplay there of the actual
combat looks awesome yeah yeah like the
bullet dodging like the bullet dodging
is awesome I got my fingers crossed that
the QuickTime event stuff is like just
mission specific well there'll be like a
couple of set you know set-piece moments
where that will happen maybe in the open
world there's like a couple of
choreographed things you can do yeah I
just I just think they wanted to go as
crazy as possible and yeah they want to
show the spectacle for the show
well like you remember like Hulk
ultimate destruction oh yeah like that
had like a really good physics system
behind it like well you know for the
time but like that lock-on was amazing
yeah well I'm like I said a helicopter
yeah so and I just want to see stuff
like that especially like with an
open-world spider-man especially now but
yeah it looks awesome like the
animations are like really fluid yeah
watch it up now you're alright you're
naves every petal with guys in this I
wonder if he could kill people cuz if
you didn't hit L right there that guys
just follow got any stories yeah I would
I would jump off the building in skydive
after him and then safe oh oh okay or or
just write him down to take him one more
time
Enya so can I talk about my my thing
almost equals now we've talked about the
missus if you want know just playing
what do you hug the thing I'm most
excited about is a guy I've never played
the franchise so this is an excellent
opportunity for me to be excited about
it I think but God of War III ever
played I've never played God of War Wow
uh listen I'm a hardcore journalist all
right really nobody I've never played a
second of it you know I take that back I
have played a few seconds of it I
thought oh it's a it's a hack-and-slash
game and but the thing about this that
excites me I don't know I'm just saying
it's just like I am smiling this way
boom like that's what I say I'm
uneducated by but if I was ever to get
into it now's the perfect time but it's
a reboot and he's got a little sunny
carry is it a reboot a little bit of
both well I I mean it looks like a
reboot right Huck in both boxes yeah
sequel but it's also kind of a recent I
mean there's nods to his past and he's
got a little Sun on his back and his
seven people in his eyes you know being
a dad how much is the having a son thing
a poll honestly being a dog being a
father a father of two daughters and no
sons yeah I guess it's my longing to
always have a son right you can change
out you know is there is there any more
manly way to vicariously live out a
father-son fantasy than being the god of
everybody yeah you know the thing about
the combat though looks way meteor than
the other heavy God Awards yeah like it
looks a little longer or zoomed in yeah
yeah I mean it's just closer over the
shoulder more so than a bug event yeah
yeah intimate hey that's the perfect
word is like when you're slicing when
you're slicing somebody's head off don't
you want it to be intimate yeah I want
to get close yeah exactly to be a
sensual experience but this excites me
like the fact that I've never played it
this is the I think that's exactly what
Sony wants for people who have never
played a God of War game they want to
get into the franchise now because they
see this this it looks good it looks
violent it looks funny like this parts
funny so you know okay yeah it's funny
so quite a bit right funny guys good
comic relief all right let's get to the
missus the bad stuff the things that you
guys are upset about and we'll start
over with you Sam starting over here
again I'm getting it
nothing Virtual Console for the switch
yeah yeah your thing was just like
everyone kind of expected here we're
gonna get this thing that we all want in
it's very clear then tendo's 25 right
there if you get yell loud enough I just
think they'll hear you
can we think reggie's and hair shots you
walk by like who's that badly Reggie
yeah just got no no Virtual Console
anything I mean it's like a staple of
Nintendo at this point you need them and
they're not they got nothing it's weird
is it like I don't I don't know and then
like you you have a game like like the
the Metroid Prime game coming out not
the metric Prime game but the eternal
salmon got the return of Samus yeah on
like a D s like which feels like it
should be there it's like yeah let me
show this gameplay they didn't even show
us the bottom screen it's like this is a
useless thing down there then I'm not
like I'm not knocking that it's on the
DS but like why not make that my not
both why not have a virtual console
where you can buy it on your switch like
giving you a teach on the 3ds first
everybody buys it and then six months
later get a surprise announcement
yes well I'm gonna switch you know yeah
you can take it out with you again I'll
switch which is great I mean and that's
the thing though we have this switch the
thing something you can take with you
right at all times
like I guarantee there's thousands of
them here at this Expo and you could be
doing the exact same thing with your 3d
s and I mean can we just be real like
3ds is kind of a dead get at this point
I'm surprised it's still around yeah it
surprised me being featured did anybody
here bring their 3ds instead of their
switch who here hasn't oh yeah hey raise
your hand people if you brought a switch
oh dang raise your hand if you brought
of 3ds okay so it's like a smattering of
yeses and it's a lot of switches yeah I
think that says I mean I like what the
switch is not you know they're still
supplying so yeah in transition but
there's more people with switches and
there are 3ds as though this is what I'm
saying though right here right now but
not in the world no not on her girl any
perfect pool of representing the world
right now just saying you guys represent
earth congratulations super what about
you Brandon I have a love-hate
relationship with Electronic Arts and
Star Wars yeah like I love the first
battlefront and I'm excited for like
everything they're doing like I play
this silly galaxy of Heroes mobile game
like every single morning but like
they're just so smug and silly about how
they sell it and like
I'm excited for battlefront - we didn't
get any updates on any other Star Wars
projects that they're doing they didn't
like announce anything new and like
they're so smug about that campaign like
there's so it's just it's so interesting
to me to have a developer like screw up
and like not do something they should
have done and then show up three years
later and be like we're doing that thing
that you were mad at us that we didn't
do and everyone's like you're awesome
it's like that no credit yeah what
happened to this about three years ago
what was in the two previous releases of
the franchise well so that's what you're
upset about at e3 is that they're giving
you a single-player campaign I'm just
upset with how to handled it okay I'm
set like they said like we're make like
with the John boyega tweet there look
look what everybody tweeted at us and
it's like that's not you just don't pat
yourself on the back you just go on
stage and you announce it you walk off
and you let everyone else kind of sorted
out what they were very like they're
acting like a top dog and they've got
like it's like our campaign is better
than the last of us and it's like we
just saw the announcement because like I
just went down a little bit down you did
it you can we talk about that for a
second the The Last of Us like that's a
is a staple of gaming journalism
whatever else but like where the hell
was it well laughing this new section
said it two ways off yeah a point before
they first showed it off to be like this
is a treat for you guys at PSX they
wanted to put this together to show you
yeah like you really gotta take those
words to heart when you're like alright
got it that's code for it's not gonna be
anything can I just be honest with you
though when everybody everybody 99.9
percent of people were expecting the
last of us to in Sony with some sort of
like hurrah or some sort of like and it
ends with spider-man yeah I mean I
thought to myself well spike well we
were talking like I was like I was like
spider-man Home Coming hitting theaters
July 7th everybody your words two words
came to mind corporate synergy right
that's exactly what though the two words
like a no okay I was disappointed about
spider-man and maybe maybe I just kind
of put it over like you open with a with
with a show like spider-man you know I
don't know but then I don't know what
you close with you get the rest of us
yeah well yeah but I mean if you have
spider-man you haven't shown anybody
gameplay like I just knew and you
should close with something that people
haven't seen yet I thought Sony the
first three or four games that they
showed we're like they're doing it again
because last year I thought they
murdered e3 I thought they nailed it
yeah awesome murder that and they were
like video games video games video games
sorry yellow except maybe not clapping I
think they just laid it out they say
showed you trailers they showed you
exactly what I think a press conference
should be yeah oh yeah they started the
exact same way and then just kind of
petered off yep you know a little
exciting again and then appeared off
again yeah yeah exactly I felt like it
opened the door I felt like especially
last year last couple years Sony being
last I don't know if they have some sort
of like last-second switch they see what
Microsoft does they see what Nintendo
does and they've been they change things
around like they have to but I always
feel like Sony just does a great job
yeah and then this year nintendo was
last even though it's all pre-recorded
they knew exactly was going on I feel
like going last on e3 gives you that
obviously the last taste and everyone
gets excited because you're the last
year last flavor yeah the news gets
buried you know yeah yeah I still think
if you blow it at e3 below it doesn't
you know it could be 10:00 in the
morning or 10:00 at night and like
people are slated you know I don't about
it make fun of you so two days ago the
Xbox one X was announced and who's
talking about the X for Xbox one X to
you well I just said right now but it's
more of a who's talking about it
definitely and I switch my miss to just
every year they have some stupid just
dance mediocrity
at Xbox oh yeah like we have to be soft
they kick it off oh you v6 you stop
sorry every year I see that I'm like
this again got like okay yeah but you
look at sales ever it sold like four
million copies and I don't know why I
don't I don't know it's not for you sir
like it just dances it's like that's you
could just dance instead you can
literally unaided by games just dance
yeah huh whatever $60 can I go back how
many all are excited about the we're
gonna talk about this more a little
later but how many all are excited about
the Xbox one X yeah okay oh yeah yeah
anyway it was a really exciting latitude
that's good new high to play the world
needs that kind of enthusiasm let me
just I want to do like an informal poll
here all right just by applause I'm
gonna name the three systems you give me
your excitement level for it alright
we'll start here I'll go with the Xbox
one and in all its varieties
round of applause how many all excited
I'm okay how many all are excited for
the Nintendo switch and how many all are
excited for the PlayStation 4 or Pro
wait let me try some here sure sure how
about the personal computer it's getting
steamed in steam ok cool just making
sure I mean I think it was probably
switch in Playstation 4 and PC it's done
yeah it's not like it was growing it's
us yeah look okay so what about you
Bolin what do you uh what did I tell you
it was because I forgot well we're going
to talk about Metro oh yeah piggybacking
on my disappointment was a general lack
of gameplay at the show and an abundance
of pre-rendered gameplay demos that uh
that like I think like we've been over
for like the past seven years or so yeah
like you know you watch the Metro demo
and like you know Metro is gonna be a
gorgeous game like it's gonna be stellar
like why like why show Y show a
pre-rendered simulation of what the
first-person like that's not like that's
not game play that's not how the game
moves like cracks me up to be so cocky
is like the this player or this person
the shooter is clearly doing things you
cannot do in a shooter I know it climbs
up the ladder and then like looks down
behind them it's like what button is
that yeah it's just I it reminds me of
Killzone to like you know the name is
Isaac but it's just like why why do it
with the game like both the Metro Metro
games are awesome if you if you guys
haven't played those like go check them
out because they're like hella cheap now
last night it was fantastic yeah and
they're awesome and they're gorgeous
like they're like benchmark games if
you're PC gamer and then it's like why
why not just play the game for us you
know to show us what it's like so I just
in Sony you know they I feel like we've
we've seen we saw more last year on the
hey here's what the game is and not
playing it yeah instead of just showing
us like something they custom-made for
the sake of a show like I think the idea
of going in and saying here's the game
let me play it for you goes a lot
further than here's again
here's a CGI cutscene yeah that shows
again what the main engine I think I
sure is there it's an engine of course
but don't yeah but still yeah like
exactly like where's the where's the
look behind you that'd be awesome
yep if you could do that but I don't
know as much as I want to hate on Star
Wars having that live battlefront
session was pretty cool
yeah it was rare I mean it is given
honest taste it was actually kind of a
bummer because that's what I came to
know Bethesda to do the last year in the
year before that is really take the
opportunity of their press conference to
show like a really long stretch of their
game what everything is honored for an
extended period of time yours fallout 4
are there to show you some more Skyrim
like you've got a thousand Let's Plays
to pick from yeah Skyrim specifically
but can we talk about that for a second
one the switch the whole Skyrim thing on
the switch yeah uh oh she controls man
yeah I get it but like yeah it's already
like a super clumsy like Skyrim is an
awesome game but like the combat is not
like some like super tight experience
like but what I'm saying though is
anybody else upset I don't know if I
talked to you about this yet Brenda but
does anybody else upset that somebody
besides the link can use the master
sword like that bothers me no one we
tried that look like link to me and like
does that bother anybody else a spitting
image I'm just saying it like bothers a
[ __ ] out of me hero of time reborn I
don't know I did did that get that guy
pull it out of the ground understand no
doubt he is I mean link goes to the
templating I'm Skyrim dude just uses an
amiibo and there it is right there well
that that's how cheap they usually like
to do it you get an amiibo now you're
the hero of time that's all you need so
we got about 10 minutes before we we do
our first stage demo of agents of mayhem
which is going to be so that'll be fun
so I'm gonna list off a few games you
guys just give me your overall thoughts
and excitement level okay um let's start
with um player Underground's battle
battlegrounds player onion okay player
on no point back away it like eighty
hours and I was gonna look over there
play unknowns battlegrounds there you go
I just know it is pop goon
look good on the Xbox overall excitement
level for that
on the Xbox was a lot of new people
streaming so it's only gonna do good
things for that brand yeah we play at a
ton and it's back because we're going
home early tomorrow so we can strain it
yeah
canceled our flight tomorrow and got a
new one so we could stream tomorrow all
day so go to subscribe to game attack
and watch play battlegrounds uh Mario
Plus Rabbids Kingdom battle who's
excited for that surprisingly excited
yeah it just looks like X come to me
like it's just straight through through
X come but without a gritty storyline
and aliens and I've read a little more
edible don't you think like x times like
hardcore like really hardcore in it with
a big rain be like rabbits was just
balls the wall hard yeah yeah it would
be awfully difficult come out there's
like slicing their hand like we're Blood
Brothers now
Detroit's become human look at all like
it yeah yeah wow like we are watching
this and and Craig was like I've zero
interest in this game you have no
interest and I and I go I go I go I go
besides minecraft there is not a game
that is the opposite of what you are all
about in video games yeah I miss oceans
the gathering in for e like I like
smarter I like my games in like 15 to 30
minute bursts of explosion yeah booms
explosions walkie wax what he's saying
is he's pretty much a mobile gamer these
days oh don't you dare no like I think I
should claims we're done if I were if I
weren't yeah yeah go go with this thing
I will murder you now right on this
stage you know it looks like it's it's
all about story and stuff and that's not
really your cup it's pretty deep yeah
it's it's it's one of those things what
I thought it like is like okay well I
get all the clues and then I'll just eat
like you know I'm an easy Street trying
to finish it and they'll still throw a
like question at you and you're like I
don't know I thought the clues would
tell me what to pick and you see you
always have to think creatively like
throughout the whole thing so I was
saying no selling tell me other day
David cage games are like the perfect
weekend rentals when you don't have
anything to do it's like you just sit
down and you blitz that mother course
like 10 hours whatever and then you're
done
so it's good and the guy from grey's
Anatomy's in there he's gorgeous oh my
goodness our next game uh-oh and the
girl from the following with Kevin Bacon
you know the following and Oh Kevin
Williamson yes nobody watched falling
that's why I got cancelled thanks a lot
three words this is the game I'm
probably most excited about see of thee
yeah yeah it looks good I'm really
excited
Brandon why are you excited about it I
just played it finally you played it oh
yeah
what is it awesome fantastic can you
wanna do you want to play together
sometimes I do
excellent yes uh what I like is that
it's not there's a there's a lot of
procedure to do there's a lot of like
like if you have like repair your ship
you're just like well take the plank out
of my bag done with that you can swim
you have to load every cannonball into
the cannon yeah like it sounds good but
I love that because you're not just like
oh I'm just gonna fire this I'm just
gonna hit X until I hit the ship it's
like yeah really aim and like okay but
for you ease into it is it gonna be see
a thieves or Skull and Bones which one
get these for me definitely the thieves
okay why um I just I love co-op more
than vs. and I didn't see a lot of
cooperative stuff happening it just kind
of looked like it was weird with see if
these because they're like 5 on 5 battle
just follows me and so I miss all those
is five on five battles yeah but it was
like I think it was they didn't really
go into it one person per ship yeah we
both thought we're like oh cool like one
on one ship battles with five people on
each ship yeah like that'll be cool I
wasn't excited about skullenbones until
like the very last second when like you
know you see like creepy cracking
tentacles cuz like we playing like Just
Cause 3 you're like any game with a huge
ocean in it and I'll just be hoping that
there's some kind of giant sea monster
as abstract never is now ever and so
skull of bones looks good but I don't
know if you can get off the ship in
Skull and Bones and stuff so I don't
believe so yeah I'd be much but they're
different which is nice yeah yeah I saw
skull bones I was like oh no poor scene
thieves but like it they're definitely
different - yeah yeah are pirates the
new zombies that was all good and evil
in pirates pirates fires fires
yeah that's it's it's it's a new wave
what's old is new again which is
exciting going to with pirates it's
gonna be really good alright this is a
nice I mean I was gonna ask Crash
Bandicoot but we know your excitement
level
on crash bandicoot yeah do you care
Brannon uh yeah I didn't I loved a
remaster of a ps1 game that's really fun
like I actually just demoed it a couple
hours ago and I was like looking in the
background I'm like wow this background
looks a lot better and it's like was
there a background in the ps1 game I
remember I'm just excited cos like
playing it while we played it at a
PACS and like you know you asked me I
was it was like it looks like my
childhood imagined it when I like it
looks the same to me but you know just
like as a kid you know that
like the ps1 was the best like you're
jumping on hippos on the surfboards and
stuff or in like the surfboard levels
and like it looks just like it did 20
years ago so I'm excited Ellie funny cuz
in 20 years when they release re
remastered and it looks way better
you'll be like it looks exactly like I
remember yeah yeah yeah totally alright
next game uh crew - I like I think the
crew - is like one of the most unique
racers full-on co-op you can do you can
do it takes like four hours to go around
the map in the cruise so it's awesome
it's like a crew anybody play the crew
nobody played the create a that's the
thing it's like like nobody like
apparently enough people played it to
warrant a sequel but no not got a sequel
that's a yes yeah justjust just being
honest here okay your sone act who's
next clearly so yeah okay okay how many
all excited for nak to know who this man
yeah well then give it a try give out ID
I mean we all got suckered in the first
time we'll make mistakes once uh it was
a good idea in concept for mark turning
turning turning mark starting mark mark
all right Wolfenstein - yeah I'm on this
bandwagon oh thank you a new Colossus
yeah they they did it once like what
four years ago it was incredible if they
can do that again I'm there I think $60
I think like I think Wolfenstein the new
order like was a return to like story
driven first-person shooter like people
crave but I don't think anybody realized
that Wolfenstein was that kind of game
yeah came out yeah like it was awesome
story intense sex scenes ultra violent
like a even multiplayer at all there I
don't think there was any multiplayer in
that game yeah exactly but just like
it's just the gameplay is just like if
you like like the new doom like that
kind of just raw like this is what a
first-person shooter should be gameplay
so nearly driven for
first-person-shooter yeah swear it said
I got one more for you real quick
actually couple quick ones we got about
three minutes for row stage show uh
South Park fractured but whole hey that
makes people giggle my roommates really
excited yeah you're not I got excited
well I don't know I mean what is it
there twenty years deep I'm a little
tired I don't think they'd be bad
worried an episode now yeah they do grid
they do a great job but it's just not my
cup of tea uh Beyond Good and Evil -
I'll tell you that yeah did y'all play
the first Beyond Good and Evil yeah hey
ya know they had a amazing animated
short yeah that I don't know anything
about that game I I think I saw a
headline from somebody that was like
it's gonna be like GTA 5 in outer space
I was like sure sure yeah I doesn't like
there's a ton of open-world games now so
like I'll just wait and see but it was
good that like who we saw had an awesome
conference because like they didn't
peter out at the end they had in it they
had they talked about games they had new
IP and they ended the show with
something like a fan favorite yeah and
the guy I can't remember the creative
directors name but he came out and cried
a little bit
I know oh it was awesome yeah he's a
good guy like love crying yeah love it
he really hairs like if he walked out
and he was just like I can't believe
this happened in tears I was like I
don't like walk deficit huh yeah genuine
this isn't short yeah why those press
conferences yeah it's like we get one
every year one guy who kind of tears up
on stage member the unravel guy the
announcement of a way out I thought was
great he was really passionate oh yeah
oh what what happened to unravel yarny
it came out and out it was pretty pretty
good was it yeah yeah did you play it
yeah I did I didn't finish it okay but
yeah that's that's yarny all right uh
last one the shadow of Colossus remake
is that uh again it's going crazy
that'll be like the fifth time I played
that yeah yeah I'm gonna play it again
it just came out of nowhere it's the
same thing like he said it's like I love
a good ps1 remake it's like oh I love a
good ps2 remake sure why not does that
look like ps4 quality to you
it was there were a couple days from
again looks a little bit better but
there was a couple that yeah the
lighting especially guys like undercover
and yeah in a beard one with a beard guy
stuff that the Sun was directly hitting
versus shadowed areas was like there's a
lot of dynamic difference there yeah
it's an excuse to play it again
so yeah hell yeah look at that it's like
a big old giant and you talk about your
15 guys it's Craig
you just won Colossus at a time yeah all
this you got up hunks one down until
it's done rinse repeat
that excites me you know you love breath
of the wild because you were like it
doesn't tell you where to go Shila
closet under the layer
I love breath the world god damnit era
there were lots of rumors about like
colossi they had a cut I think like they
were like a dozen in the game or
something and there was like 40 that
they originally planned yeah like like
in my opinion kind of dumb for like a
ps2 game I don't know what the hell yeah
yeah but I wonder if they're gonna maybe
slip some some extra ones in there
that'd be cool some Easter eggs
fingers crossed well thank you guys that
was exciting
it's now time for our stage demo of
agents of mayhem so everyone give give
Brandon and Sam a round of applause Sam
will be joining us in just a minute
Brandon is gonna get the hell out of
here and go enjoy stuff on the floor of
you guys what are you doing tonight good
III tonight drink it you hear that
everybody Brandon Jones is drinking
alright excellent I thank you Brian
appreciate it okay guys have a good time
now let's let's get a let's get our
friends up let's so let's check out
agents of mayhem where's everybody at
let's let's bring him up all right here
we go
hey guys come on up man
hey how are you I'm Craig a new all
right nice to meet you
Sean let's do this thing baby this is
just you oh yeah I did my OD Ryan oh let
me switch oh let's do this hey I'm Sean
hello will say hello to will will powers
everybody all right we'll tell us about
agents of mayhem oh sorry
yes by all means tell us about agents of
me okay so agents of mayhem it's
basically a GI Joe type game where
you're basically controlling an agency
called mayhem they have 12 agents that
they go to take out legion legion is
this terrorist organization they have
attacked all around the world and
here right now there in Seoul South
Korea they're doing up to something
you're trying to figure it out
so you deploy your agents into the city
to figure out what's going on
would you mind if would you mind looking
at that lady in the dress a little bit
more please what Wacka
oh my goodness I know the horrible
outfit for work I know I mean I think
I'm nervous it's not Pratt's operating
criticism to the game but man those
heels she's gonna have blisters slice of
pancakes she's French
she's French yes make his French she's
the she's the head of mayhem
she's a head of mayhem yes is she
working the desk you know somewhere up
top looking down at everybody what you
guys go look at that chest everyone's so
good looking I know everyone so gorgeous
so what are we gonna see so this is uh
one of the lieutenant's August gaunt he
sort of might remind you of a pop star
you might have seen on TV
he's uh he's basically uh seems to be
brainwashing a lot of his fans for some
mysterious purpose so one of the things
going down to do is oh yeah what he's up
to
yeah he's brainwashing them with with
sex yes
that's gone so what okay
all right so he's brainwashing everybody
and your job is to murder him or you to
be him
well you might want to be him but really
you're trying to find out figure out
what he's doing why he's brainwashing
them and what he wants to hae-in
Thompson and stop him from doing that do
you think this would work in real life
if you got up and started pelvic
thrusting for one to subscribe to game
attack no okay I'm just asking would it
maybe we'll try after that yeah maybe
maybe what some time to kill is a good
if games if GameSpot allows it oh
they'll allow it so what was you know so
I've seen in a lot of ads that GATS
coming back in this yeah what where
where does the where does the saint roll
line stop and where does agents of
mayhem begin so uh this is universe
right it's yes and the idea is in Saints
Row got out of hell at the very end
Johnny Gat
basically meets God and God gives him
such an option of what he wants to do
one of the choices is he can sort of
recreate the universe okay and sages
mayhem universe
essentially one of those new universes
that was create some like in that
universe he shows up as a cop and so
that's just background as an agent of
mayhem he comes from as a soul cop
awesome okay cool cool
so you said how many how many agents are
there so there are 12 agents that come
right out of the box a gat would make it
13 but the idea is you'll unlock them as
you play
but once you've unlocked them they can
play in any of the missions other than
the personal missions that they that are
around them so you the idea is to
basically play through a mission see
which combination works for you and
choose what agents you like depending on
the situation or your play style I got
you so so what are you doing right now
mister will I'm editing the skins of any
different agents so one of the things
that we have here is there's 12
different agents like like like for you
oh thank you sir
there are 12 different agents like a new
mention but all of them have their
different personality types and in
different things that make them special
so if you look here I'm going to be
choosing Yeti who if you are fan of
Saints Row franchise
you'll recognize as kind of a
reincarnated version of Oleg from
previous game like was a big mother
Craig or dave bautista like yeah but uh
his name is Yeti in this game and this
is the incredible Yeti
well I have a huge issue hit my arms
tired
it's all good so we're just gonna jump
right into the into the demo this is a
squad I've chosen kingpin who is Pierce
Washington from previous Saints Row
games in this University's reimagined as
someone who reunited or United the gangs
of Stillwater instead of dividing them
from the Saints than the Pierce is like
the number 2 in the same show games
right yes yeah he's yeah he's one of the
bosses lieutenants and but here he sort
of is the boss and that joins mayhem
because he was able to stop Legion and
before God you gotcha so we had what uh
what's called a kind of a drop sequence
here the deploy sequence you your three
agents that you choose you choose three
agents got in the field every time kind
of a mixed match of different weapon
types different tactical advantages and
different strategy but they all kind of
deploy with to some some very superhero
thematic music as you drop into the city
yeah basically they come in the idea is
that uh they can teleport in so right
now you're playing as kingpin but he can
sort of swap at will so if he wants to
switch to Oni or Yeti he can do that and
the idea is as you're fighting you'll
you'll do an ability or make an attack
with one switch to another guy take
advantage of that so like Yeti can
basically freeze enemies and then you
can switch to Oni and quit quit them
while they're frozen myheco in the head
so right so when you assemble your squad
it is you are in control at all times
yes like AI is controlling you though -
correct
yeah so is it there's online co-op
correct no though it's a totally
single-player game okay
yeah it's we idea is we really wanted
people feel like they were in full
control of the agency and they didn't
need other people in order to do that he
just shoot himself backwards into the
car yes that's awesome yeah each one of
the agents they get they have their own
unique entries into the vehicles they
all have their own unique special
abilities and mayhem abilities which are
they're super super powers essentially
they have special gadgets that they can
equip that are again unique to them when
you play a mission they will respond to
people at the base or the enemies and
they all have their own unique lines so
one of the fun things to do is replay
the missions with different agents and
see how they respond to things so what
is the what is the objective of what's
what you're going to be doing right now
so basically he's the trying to figure
out where auguste comte is so you can
figure out like what he's doing so you
find out you you've gotten information
that he's he was just at a nightclub
nearby so you're gonna drive over there
alright got it got it got it okay so
each of these agents has special
abilities are they kind of like on a
cool-down
yeah the special ability is on cooldown
and then when every time you fire them
off it builds up your mayhem bar and
when that fills up then you can
user mayhem ability because your mayhem
bar is kind of like an ultimate attack I
guess yes from each agent has their own
individual one it's keyed off their
personality and their play style nice
so kingpins I think hopefully we'll be
able to see at some point here his this
is quite quite good oh they know
something's about to go down here so
he's reached the animations are great
well I'm trying to get the mayhem meter
yeah so you use your special abilities
the bill that they may have made okay so
yeah it's been kingpin special is he
basically just throws his gun and it
explodes and then he gets a new one all
right are you guys cool if we have does
anybody else here have any questions
about the game are you guys cool we take
out absolutely scene we have any
questions about the game or know that by
all means I mean I think okay if you
anybody oh yes what let's get them in a
microphone yeah let's go come on over
here thank you uh so you guys said that
this wasn't a multiplayer game is there
a split-screen maybe no nope no co-op is
this totally single-player 100%
single-player yep
okay that's oh yeah sorry I like how
excited he gets to get in the car take
that back :
hey here you guys are trying to focus on
the diverse play styles in combining the
different character abilities right
right so you sold the car you're making
away go find him again yeah so basically
you find out he wasn't there but he the
bouncer saw him take off in one of his
garish cars so you're heading over to an
underground parking garage nearby where
he sort of stores his vehicles so you
can find out more information so your
character's kingpin are you calling that
car to you is that his custom car that
you guys were talking about yeah so
basically there's a 12 agent vehicles
that you can unlock though the game and
they all have their own skins too and
some in each car has a unique skin for a
specific agent as well nice alright cool
you guys obviously looking for
ridiculous over-the-top fun yes yes
absolutely I've been sued one of our
trademarks and we yes HS Pam is
definitely an applause for particles
what's going on all right here we go so
yeah we'll reach the parking garage here
with all Gaunt's cars so so what you're
saying is that video games should be fun
we like to think so yeah yeah it's like
his license plate
yes very telling well where can I get
your shoes goodly how order so uh these
are old Saints were the third shoes that
we had specifically made for those so
they're purple snakeskin custom customer
ah cheese you not to brag about it
definitely the kid okay so he's
basically looking at all the various
cars not not finding the information he
needs and then also dawn is sort of on
to him and they've sent out a bunch of
enemies okay way to take him out so he
can freeze them yes I would think you
just be able to rip their heads off he's
so giant he's got a freeze right you
don't need to do that yeah I mean why
work out so hard this guy's kind of like
stealth character got the cloaking so
yeah stole combo wombo combo yes he said
he's a formerly a jock assassin so he
basically has a lot of skills at where
you can kill enemies quickly and also
like hide and attack from the claw start
love these I love these reload
animations he's got going on can you
yeah he's just like whatever I don't
need that anymore I just give me a new
one I love that phone I love that to the
guy who loves the reload animation
animation to me is like the most
important game or thing in videogames
you cannot like you can you can improve
player experience so much with little
stuff like that
yeah and that was that was a big focus
of our animation team they wanted to
relieve view each agent with their you
know their personality and yeah that
comes through you know how they run how
they jump
Pelly lumber around how they freeze
stuff and then it make it explode well
yeah like you're talking about freezing
something making you explode one of the
big things that you have here is because
you have three agents it's combining
their abilities so with Yeti you freeze
them with the freeze ray and then you
can turn into Oni and hit him with a
bunch of head shots at the silenced
pistol
so it's about kind of maximizing the
combination of their skills what kind of
what kind of benefits are there for the
player in using the combinations uh the
idea is basically because they have
different abilities and they they buff
themselves or debuff the enemies in
specific ways certain agents other
agents can take advantage of those okay
changes tell me where to go all right
oh man so look at that car yeah I think
it's his he's a little foot full of
himself yeah yeah yeah everywhere what
that's actually what do you thought your
car looks the same the same fine yeah
hey modeled it after mine yeah my Nissan
Rogue
so those damage numbers coming off the
car right there
yeah guys yeah that's so you you know we
want to show you the damage number so
you can see when you make changes how
effective or ineffective those changes
are when you or you're battling enemies
like when you upgrade your feet when you
when you up here the vehicles or when
you when you upgrade your gadgets or
upgrade your agent of course if you want
to see that damage output what what the
difference is yeah make educated choices
essentially what consoles should we
expect this on so it's gonna be on PC
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one no switch huh
no no switch don't boo them yeah Pindos
fault they can't control it they can't
make a console to power this is badass
mother can I ask you it like can I ask
you a legitimate questions sure as a
developer is it is it hard to develop
for for Nintendo who tries to think
outside the box with the way they would
they way they present their games and
making a really old tablet that's what
I'm saying it's hard to develop for an
old tablet can you I mean I mean I'm
gonna I'll take this one
because Anoop sweating as your ass
connect sorry hard-hitting journalism
Turtles of hardcore let's go one of the
things that you got to do here is when
you're planning and making a game you
you're making a game years and years in
advance and you're choosing and you're
choosing based off obviously what you're
first what you're seeing uh the console
landscape or the landscape of the
industry to be at the time when you
think the games can release for Alex
which isn't even on the range radar
right honestly like switch
switch development kits weren't even a
thing that was that was even a thought
error concept and in anyone's head when
we started development for this project
so when you're when you're doing that
you have to plan way in advance to be
able to target what platforms
re-released for so we don't hate
Nintendo oh absolutely not
go out that next time for yes open their
mouth Craig I think it's a lot I think
the question you guys probably want to
know that gets the answer to that right
right I'm a voice of the people bull
right so who when you gonna murder
somebody I wanna see some someone die
hopefully well so you know as a typical
you know volition game you know you can
murder peds and we don't really we don't
we don't reward you for it but we don't
really penalize you for it either
because for for mayhem the job isn't to
necessarily save the world is to stop
Legion collateral damage is okay is this
a is this - ability just like is that
one of kingpins moves so the majority
the agents have the - ability some can
actually do it in the air like like
kingpin but then some agents like owning
that's hot instead of dashing bait they
do the cloak ability okay so here we're
actually like chasing down gone by the
smell of his Cologne that's sort of been
left around here gotcha the stench is
worse there it is yep nice man what is
it's a 60% of the time it works every
time
thumbs up franker man oh well it looks
like he was actually waiting for us so
that's not actually him that's a
hologram of him oh and he's he's just
flicking you off and oh man
see that's where the demo should just
end right there you and then cut coming
soon to everything but switch shut up
Greg no just we're having fun here so
you're gonna hack to find out if you can
get more information but again it's a
trap so enemies are waiting so now wills
going to take in town get on that so
yeah we'll fill up the mayhem meter here
which is that purple bar above his
shield and health and hopefully we can
get that up
wombo combo so frozen oh look at that
that's awesome just did the stuff got
obliterated I was it standing ice to
meet you yeah thank you
I like him not everybody knows Batman
and Robin quotes from that Batman Robin
yeah that one's out made that one up oh
yeah you made that up that's good Oh
lots of different enemy classes looks
like you got like the nimble ninjas and
you got this just kind of tanky guy yeah
so basically had this the swarm troopers
that the ones who are sort of rushing at
him warm troopers yeah and then the
shock trooper is that big guy that was
jumping around and he basically does
like a ground pounder I get ready boss
this is kingpins mayhem abilities I like
that he's getting shot and he's like
yeah whatever yeah oh so he drops his
boom box Oh get on that let's go home
doggystyle it's on it are dancing any
enemy in that that purple area basically
is is affected so it's basically a stun
attack but it's it's a kingpin style
can I just add a little bit like just
for fun just a little critique do not
suggest stuff to game developer yeah
absolutely I will I want them to die
from dancing so hard I just want the
football over cuz like hocus-pocus yeah
they're dancing so hard they're they're
just air humping so hard I think I'm
glad I'm glad that it's just a stun
because then you can come in with with
Hulk Yeti man and then do the super
smash and then like knock their ass up
that was basically what we wanted to
make sure that you other agents would
take advantage of that oh that move but
to be fair we did discuss something like
that dude all it got cut Oh Craig that
was a sympathy remark I know they didn't
really think about that I know just
trying to make you feel better it's okay
half my life bowling okay so you're
gonna track him down he's gonna go oh
yeah you're the ideas you get out of
this temple and you're trying to figure
out exactly where he did go probably to
the X I know he's got there's this raid
that's nearby you're gonna
I got over there how long have you been
working on this personally uh three and
a half years on this I see he's been
working for three and half years he's
still laughing we kick someone in the
ass like you still laughs that it
happens in our studio to like all the
time people are just laughing at silly
stuff that that you can do man this is
Austin that's exactly the type of game I
want though I want games you can do
silly stuff in and be stupid make be
three years you still can't drive good
though that that's that's that's an
issue you got to work on that you're
closing in so can you give me a spoiler
and let me know like do you kill him at
the end of the demo or does he get away
are we gonna see are we gonna find out
nobody nobody nobody everything let's
just wait and watch
wheels like shut up you just put them in
a position where we're gonna be really
happy you're really sad I know thanks is
no middle ground I'm gonna be ecstatic
either way you kidding me I just asked
he's open into questions and hope they
answer what's the meaning of life will
those purple shoes that's how the
meaning of life again yeah I'm not even
watching the gameplay I'm just really
looking at the toe of his parking skins
it's so good I got I got you all right
so uh so the cool thing here is we're
going this is right in my mouth I was
trying to help you lean back seat in it
so you could stay comfortable yes so
we're going into a rave here in in a
congregate saner hold um and I want I
want Craig to guess what the what the
bouncers gonna say when we show up now
she's gonna say I think it won't matter
cuz you're gonna make him dance hes
gonna fall over and die that's what I
think he's gonna say you're under great
one of those two things is correct so
easy to say he's gonna say you're too
good-looking you can't come in always
like the bouncers oh here we go okay
okay Mike out for will always said this
[ __ ] again I can say that
because it's no you can't I can say it
it's in the game no you can't a secret
watch your mouth he's gonna shoot you
shoot him don't shoot him yes no well
don't want to see we'll shoot him
no I'll shoot him
Oh God Almighty that maid had a family
video games
we'll take he was a jerk I like that
these guys didn't even stop built like
there's like any others you're like some
still having a great time
either we're spaced out for some reason
I got you so I'm gonna let you guys
watch the cutscene but I I have to point
out that the all the work that volition
did creating one this character who's my
personal favorite enemy in the game and
fighting him is the best but just they
created a musician but not only created
a musician they created his songs as
well there are multiple songs in the
games that are written and produced in
full fully fleshed out there's chewing
gum til I'm crazy there's weeps for my
peeps these are like crazy pop songs
that you can't get out of your head and
they're the best
so will you be releasing a soundtrack
that's the question there's no joy
that's the look of a man who didn't
think about that yet we get the royalty
what's the 20% all right the idea that's
awesome thank you so much for your
generosity and letting us see I I just
got one oh of course it has clearly a
thought of that clearly there might
there might be something in the window
exclusive pre-order the game right now
oh shut up
we might be spoiling that might have
been the plan of like we're gonna do
that if you just shut up we're gonna
announce you at the end of the demo it's
okay or never gonna be able to do this
again to shut your hole I'm sorry
professional journalism all right so
we're getting into the big fight now
this is this is a big fight but it's not
with gone again he's here this is a
hologram because he's like you know it's
this is not cool enough for him
essentially so I'm unfortunately you're
there's a bunch of like possessed
brainwashed brave demands that are
thought to come after you so you got to
destroy these transmitters that are
basically row X I'm trying to take
control of them you're not supposed to
you don't have to kill the enemies the
of the people but you can but the main
thing is to take out these transmitters
did you say throw exit them eat that
leave me alone oh my gosh they're all
over you so when they were there closely
the thing that can't be killed
unfortunately okay so you're just
hitting them and tearing ripping off
their headsets yes yeah okay you're not
actually hurting the nice dancing people
yeah but you can there you go well
there's well oh oh well the game was too
awesome for itself that's what happens
sometimes well that's okay
pre-release code rewrite yeah uh this is
what sometimes pre-release code isn't
don't ever apologize don't ever
apologize round of applause
wait it's a ma'am we Craig made me dance
and rave too hard yeah yeah that's
that's what happens I throw a good party
it's good that's great yes thank you so
much for uh for showing that off it was
really fun yeah thank you guys so much
for having us a newb coming out from
Champaign Illinois bringing the party
out here but uh this time of year really
hot really very hot yes sixty in
Illinois okay no no no it's like an 80s
and 90s only yeah thanks for braving
never even the weather yeah yeah so last
thing agency BAM comes out August which
was why we're showing out August gone
today August 15th for ps4 Xbox one and
PC excellent just let you know game
attack colors are purple our motto is
bleed purple we came up with that before
twitch ever did just letting you guys
know uh well they came up with purple
ten years ago with we know Queen is
gonna get some of these shoes that's how
you journalism right okay that's how you
journaling you back into a corner give
around pause guys thank you very much
for coming thanks guys thank you Russia
will be in contact so everybody goes out
and buys it it's gonna be great thank
you alright Sam get you up here buddy
let's let's continue our hard hardcore
journalism here all right so now the
part of the time where I'm gonna read
off yeah yeah that's mine thank you very
much phones every
well right there all right excellent so
uh that was fun that was really fun
thank you guys that's great
okay so now I want to talk Xbox and Sony
because they're you know their
competitors they're kind of one of the
same title of the chair
yeah take up the whole thing don't make
it look like when I can where's Marlin
where's Marley Marley can you come sit
why did you sit on stage you know we
allowed to do that yeah we can do
whatever we want
who wants to go on stage with us who
wants Marlin the sound guy to come on
state come on guys their producers Sam
Sam pick somebody I'll go there yeah
guys pick somebody to show you pick
somebody what he's the one who gets in
trouble if you're wrong so should I try
this Oh Sam you Sam girl grow some balls
and pick somebody pick someone get get
this guy right here in the blue shirt
he's been very active yeah hehe yeah
sure see you just picked him come on
yeah yeah yeah what cuz you won't make
the decision he's got pineapples no no
don't give him a mic though don't give
him the money
don't look like you can't get you to no
Mike you can't talk you just sit he's
sitting out anyways what do you want to
talk about I want Microsoft and Sony so
I missed those few minutes ago right
yeah we talked we talked about Xbox one
X ryos announced couple yeah go smaller
version it's more powerful and said it
was heavier you said the Xbox head when
X was heavier heavier than all the other
ones why would you what made you look
that up I liked it a spec sheet and you
you were like oh it weighs that many
pounds I should go look at the other
ones no it had them all side by side
okay wait what Jacob it's also that host
what is your name Thomas excellent Thank
You Thomas Thomas Thomas doesn't get a
Mike everyone round of applause for no
Mike Thomas over here very good
excellent
no Mike Thomas it's a good nickname yeah
thank you yeah okay so the question is
Xbox 1x $4.99 $499 okay yeah pretty
pricey pretty pricey game though with
switch with a 299 right is that what it
wasn't game on you can buy a gold ps4
right now for 250 like what's up with a
scrappy so the big question yes sir the
ps4 pro what's one of those costs I
don't know I think those are 399 right
ps4 grows $9.99 yet so a phantom guy
confirmed it
permits like Wikipedia out there yeah
the way you should the way he looked at
it was like this yeah that's a new uh
journalism so who is the Xbox one X made
for I think that's the kind of that bit
I don't know I think this ad is also one
of the worst ads I've seen in a long
time and saying this like I couldn't
tell like if I didn't know better I
would not be sure if it was a new
controller or what because well then
just as much time showing you the
controller that's something I'm very
familiar like the Wii U and it sounds
exactly the same it's it's it's just
like but people know what it is it's
like this is at least an enthusiast
product it's like the Xbox controller it
is a it is a special it's like a special
item for people that need to go the
extra mile
yeah but don't take the people we're
gonna go an extra mile to make their
games look good already have a PC yeah
right yeah yeah like if you're gonna
drop like well in $500 to like if you
wanted to go into cheap and buy used
parts and stuff you could build a decent
computer for $500 yeah I think that's
the thing like I want to be really clear
like we're not bashing on this at all
like we did we love games we just want
to be real about it as well so but I
think that's the thing that we finished
up is saying like my my first thought
was that names really stupid right
it reminds you that we you and not the
Wii U but the name the game itself
because the Wii U name was confusing as
hell and when you ask you can ask people
today about the Wii U and they're like I
have no idea what that is you know but
if you ask people with the Xbox one X's
first all the Xbox one is a horrible
name
maybe throw an X at the end of it now
it's just Xbox one Xbox one Xbox one you
just it's just in the Infinity and they
wanted it in an anagram I don't know I
think saying you should switch places
because I just thought about something
well your lower third it's gonna say
he's Brandon Jones and it's gonna say
that you haven't are gonna do they're
aware they're aware
ya know my guess is he's fine no Mike
Thomas is know Mike Thomas I think
you're good there you're okay you're
okay Mike Thomas
there's your no Mike Thomas I can tell
you our producer running around though
yeah yeah I guess I'm running your
I'm sorry no Mike Thomas all I want you
to do is just react with great facial
expressions the entire time acts thank
you very much uh so shocked okay
excellent
who here right just buy a round of
applause
who here plans to buy an xbox one X day
one okay
few people know know how many I want to
wait X wait six months to see the Xbox
one X rate up applause okay okay if if
you said you you're gonna buy an xbox
one X day one raise your hand if you
said you would and also raise your hand
if you said you would but you don't have
an Xbox regular right now yeah that's
actually a good thing so you don't know
guys
oh you're gonna buy it and that's gonna
be your first also I think the first
real question asked in this whole thing
is who owns a 4k TV like any of you did
this is legitimate question does 4k
gaming matter to you guys do you care
like ripping like my rattle up by round
of applause clap if you don't care about
4k gaming now clap if you do care about
4k gaming okay I mean I think that's
just interesting to me because I how
many frickin polygons can you get I mean
it's a how big a but you just sound like
an old man like oh yeah I sell 180 I
clearly don't like this what's that like
in 1080 was plenty at the time tane t is
plenty right now yeah it's all it is
it's it's a matter of standardization in
a couple of years when 4k TVs are all
six hundred eight hundred bucks like ten
ATP's we're a couple years ago like
it'll be the standard yeah just like 3d
TVs were wait no but that's your veteran
given technology not just moving up this
location every year TV TV companies need
something to sell they need to sell you
as if you have a t so it's gonna be all
like well solution TVs no because you
already bought whatever that years ago
when they needed buy to buy more okay
actively looks better like if you get
out a microscope I'm saying it doesn't
matter that money be your old man eyes
does not matter at all with the rest of
us have seen 4k TV
no.not away and apparently I'm long just
like everybody out here they they agree
the four not do not marginalize him you
did not say every vibe replay everybody
out guy not every guy who's not paid
attention to Marlon Marlon sound guy
right there easy said he's really Marlon
Marlon must shut up Marlon
no see okay but Marlon is clearly a
person who knows Tech he is in the world
his job is he knows sec yeah and so he's
the person a little most people don't is
what I'm saying most people don't care
yeah in most people are you know say go
say it go say it good you you
marginalize everybody or not know most
people just aren't informed or consumer
electronics that's why we're 83 do you
barely you're not smart enough per se
not armed it back get under control
everybody the cameramen are having a
great time right now and that's bad for
us no it's great eventually 4k will be a
2 or K will be a standard yes just
bounce acknowledging of course it will
let's talk about games in Assassin's
Creed origins I'm excited I'm excited
for Assassin's Creed or yeah it's I
don't care about the roots it's ten
years old and it's the 13th one yeah no
- okay I'm just excited because like I
skip like every every two or three
Assassin's Creed games
I went from I played one and two and
then I skip to like Black Flag and Black
Flag was like masterpiece and so I
waited
I didn't play unity or syndicate and now
I'm ready for this one because I think
it's the same team as uh Black Flag yeah
and it looks awesome
and oh you cannot tell me that 4k
display obsessed creed origins did not
look stellar over there at the movie saw
huh okay it looks exquisite yeah so does
1080 just whatever yeah it looks great I
love it don't-don't-don't trigger this
dude look at he's about a snap he's
about to go crazy right now
you're know Mike Larry you're over there
for you know and I'm really hey Greg
he's about to go you know what I really
want
what's that knees for klg ultra wise
yeah
I see explain over there that's it looks
good look good so yeah all of us were
talking about how we just want to play
battlegrounds on the better TV so you
guys have good monitors at home not that
good at least they actually said we get
with the three of us get to leave with
one of those oh that's nice
no not really you're not out what else
you got hey producer Dragon Ball
fighters see yeah it looks like what you
want from it it's like oh I always
wanted to have a dragon well fight oh
yeah we're gonna make it like this hand
drawn thing I'm like oh great good job
yeah look gorgeous done it hopefully
it'll be an actual fighting game it's
like you can't do 3d fighting games in
have them be like flying away fighting
game I know that's what I'm saying the
other ones are good but they can't be
super competitive because of their style
I always thought Budokai just boiled
down to a bunch of nonsense happening
because like like it's it's - you're
moving like you're Goku you're moving
like faster than anyone apprehend like
I've got more nonsense so clean so clean
oh my goodness I love that like how it
goes into cutscenes and it's seamless
which is good I mean it looks it looks
like this it looks like the show in HD
yes it does it looks like the you know
which is great and I don't I don't watch
anime and I want to play this which is
great oh you just don't why are you
pulling that yeah I'm it's bringing me
into the scene like that's a good thing
right that's what you okay yeah yeah
there's no way I this is a this is the
branch to bring me in which is excites
me it looks fun and exciting it's 3v3
right battle yeah yeah yeah yeah which
seems like a bit much but maybe not
what's whatever my eyes can we look it
we've got a we've had a No
anime stance on game attack for a while
but we may have to break it yes for this
game it's fun because you guys do stuff
like that and make Megan actual games
yeah a good look like but now we'll get
into it because you approve sir there it
is like the Miami Heat fan approve all
right let's talk we talked about anthem
a little bit ago yeah which was fun but
let's talk about so what will school
gloss over that let's talk about the
Uncharted DLC it's not DLC although the
in charted expansion or whatever it's a
game ticket to full game yeah
okay the Uncharted thing all right the
Uncharted game which apparently okay we
talked about we talked about why last of
us wasn't on the PlayStation
yeah Druckman said that he wanted to
give this some some you know some
spotlight so this is a full game yeah
cool right they did the record I love
you journalism is this right journalism
ball game right excellent well I don't
think it's me they think it's awesome
yeah nothing cuz they add the Nathan
Drake and it's like okay we had enough
games now let's like move over to two
new protagonists like we're done with it
yeah yeah so I'm excited lesson charted
game I thought the last one should have
been yeah the right thing with making it
new people if they're gonna have another
one switch out the protagonist let's be
anybody didn't hear my plan charted for
here it's about everybody is there maybe
not like the baddest ever that's her
name right Nadine the one that whoops
don't spoil ish she whoops [ __ ] out
Nathan Drake a couple of times he's
gonna let you know she like lets them
have it is awesome I don't think there's
ever a need to not have a like hey with
fun adventure treasure hunting game so
why not be a sure there should always
just be a new one on the rise yeah why
not it could be worse like I mean I
don't like Assassin's Creed that much
but people still buying them yeah
keep give I mean if they're at five
sasses Creed's a thirteen they got a
ways to go but yeah it's tired we don't
need to talk about just dance let's get
into our neighbor over here fifteen feet
behind us Nintendo do let's talk Mario
Odyssey yeah
who's excited for Mario Odyssey
who's kind of weirded out with the whole
city and real people and realistic
dinosaurs they also let you don't care
cuz it's still Mario it's gonna be
awesome like he takes over people yeah
like the thing I'm most stoked about is
that like everything gets a mustache
which is dope like when the t-rex had a
mustache I was all-in so I I mean I'm
sure be great what a weird never view
though like the idea of opening up with
a shot of a dinosaur and say yeah yeah I
thought it was AI was like oh it's the
new Monster Hunter game on the on the DS
huh how many L saw a monster on our game
when he saw that like I mean it's one of
those things where you look at it and
you go okay and then oh hello Mario is
my first thought immediately was the
original Martin the Mario movie like oh
yeah I know sources that's a horrible
idea that's that's it but yeah so here's
the game place like a it's kind of like
a little sub challenge world here yeah
yeah it looks like there's like the
Rockets take you to kind of like
challenge stages basically but I don't
know like at first the city thing was
like kind of off-putting it was kind of
like that sonic oh-6 thing yeah but that
like everybody hated for a good reason
but uh I don't know I kind of warmed up
to it Mars you got a moon and then you
become a rocket with a mustache so sold
yep just that sentence alone he got a
real nice tactile rocket with a mustache
I'm in it's good so the thing about that
I was watching and as I learn more about
the game so you there's the currency
itself coins are actually worth
something in this game they're not worth
like lives at a hundred you actually
spend them to get the outfits and spend
them to get little collectibles yeah you
got to go accessorize my new hat yeah so
so if you look in the upper left corner
there there's like traditional coins
then every every world has its own
currency every land habits has its own
type of currency so you go to Canada you
get Canada dollars and you go to LACMA
stock when you get in block my sock my
dollars yeah you go to United States you
got US dollars right yeah it kind of the
same thing here where you know you in
everything allocated whatever world
you're in yeah so you can wait to see
though where it like marks off the zone
like you can't actually go yeah you're
just like in a little in a little chunk
right here it's
like you're going to go over there to
the Brooklyn Bridge or whatever okay so
this I was actually watching this
earlier and I think the developers were
talking about this so at this point I
think this is exactly so guy who's
playing was saying that he couldn't
figure out to get how to get to that
musician on top of the building so he
climbed to the top of this just to do a
plain old jump across and the developer
was like yeah that's not how you're
supposed to do it but but but they
figured it out it was pretty funny so
apparently there's more than one way to
solve each puzzle whatever cuz that's
how you kind of wanted to be yeah yeah I
mean this is the first the the press
release it just get the sound of Mayor
the press release says is the first
first open-world game in 15 years
thank you Bowl that's very spin sunshine
right first yeah first Mario position
yeah yes which is great we needed
another one they've all been good
there's the big job a like yeah he's
gonna make it
yeah look at this he's okay don't look
at those knees oh my god what else you
got okay so uh yeah I don't know like
this excites me it's all so weird to me
uh I know we talked about the city's
landscape thing yeah yeah I'm always the
person who complain about them not doing
anything news so they're doing some new
great great happy done that's all me but
the later levels look like traditional
Mario stuff with yeah yeah yeah which is
good it's got a wide variety of stuff
going on though okay uh next Mario thing
and next Mario think nice Nintendo thing
uh the Yoshi game Yoshi I was like her
this likely thing up I wonder when they
decided that Yoshi should be like that's
the game where we're gonna do a weird
art style and just like oh he's gonna be
yarn or jelly or cardboard or whatever
like biggie they can't just have even
though it's just named Yoshi they can't
just have Yoshi anymore he's got to be
this oh it is cardboard I didn't even
notice when you're watching on your
iPhone earlier yeah but it's all
cardboard but it's one of those things
where Yoshi
ever since he oh she's island it's
always had a weird art style it's always
had a different art style so he's always
yeah the guy who's they take chances
with and make it look cute but now it's
even more so in its I would say it's
like gone too far anything it's just
like I'd rather I'd like a Yoshi game
that's not like here's a visual gimmick
yeah
I don't know I feel like Yoshi games are
like the perfect handheld games because
they tend to be a little bit easier and
you don't have to like zero in on and
play it like this you know what I mean
you don't have to you know to focus so
much when you play is so lacks to play a
Yoshi game yeah and the thing is Yoshi
games there lacks but they could be they
could get pretty difficult
yeah later on by like I remember Yoshi
maybe it was Kirby's Epic Yarn as well
like was it Kirby's yeah yeah yeah but
that game was like just so chill and
like easy to pick up and play and you
didn't have to like it's not the kind of
game you have to commit like six hours
to every time you sit down like breath
of the wild or it's like I don't have to
go do all this stuff on that exact same
note I think Kirby's just a better
option for that yeah
and that's well they announced in
everything exactly it that looks
excellent like I'm Way more hyped about
Kirby than I am yoshi or probably mario
alright looks like here's the question
for the audience uh we're gonna go Kirby
or Yoshi okay raise your hands you're
more excited for or clap if you're more
excited for Yoshi oh my gosh birthday
excited that's great
clap you're more excited for Kirby Wow
as Kirby Tate like cares it's Kirby more
uh yes
Billy is it the entire planet I think oh
oh they have decided get in the world of
like memes and cute cats and stuff yeah
Kirby yeah alright let's talk about the
I guess the bombshells today Metroid
Prime for okay see okay that's some of
the most noise we've heard all day and
all it was with some text like it was
like it was literally like hot nebulous
gas came on the screen and it was just
like Metroid Prime furnace would be a
doozy sure and then there it is spirited
stop shopping BAM
oh yeah that's the entirety of it
everybody was going wild yeah well so
did you guys see the leaked like the
supposedly 'kz Nintendo thing that came
out like earlier this week yeah yeah
like it was a rundown of all the games
that they were gonna now
right and I don't love it wasn't
accurate with it but one of them was a
Metroid 2-d game yeah we're both the
switch and the 3ds right so when they
announced that might when I saw the for
my first initial thought was essentially
like Super Metroid - right like digging
is taking the next step because I think
there's been an official sequel to now -
Metroid it's just been like you know
spin-offs and I am yeah I am yeah but
other room doesn't count we all know
whether a fusion other end is not canon
other one was not good but and then of
course they have reached was it's a
mystery turns that was called return of
Samus yeah yeah uh mr. Davis returns
this is the 3ds 3ds gate it looks
awesome like it just it just really
makes me mad that it's not Anse on my
beautiful News HD switch and it's still
at hot 720p check this out right she
walks up BAM hits you and when she does
the man that freakin this is like really
fast doglike thing comes at her and she
like does on some kind of swoosh eerie
free fat y'all see you there and second
here we go yeah I just it really made me
wish it was just at least available on
switch yeah I don't even play it in like
this really look what just here comes oh
that's hot and she grabs the tail yeah
this is hella dope yeah yeah it looks
really cool like at least we got game
playing stuff and I'm like I'm there
that's that I'm there done I mean it's
what people I was talking to bowling
about this couple days ago but like I
think those two e3s ago uh there you
know Nintendo had their their events and
Reggie had a Samus pin yeah and
everyone's like what's the samus pin 4
and he's like I don't know something may
be happening I was like two years ago
you know so to see something actually
announced today was pretty pretty
awesome yeah so III do wish that they'd
my dream is a super metroid remake yeah
and like beautiful I like HD yeah yeah
like a beautiful hinge dch 240 DS yeah
whatever it is okay uh they also
announced a new Pokemon game for this
switch a Pokemon a problem another one
where they just Reggie
yeah they did but they didn't show
anything on that nothing out of a casual
make everybody it's great how many what
20 years of us being like make a console
game and then they're like okay yeah are
you pumped for Pokemon in the living
room yeah can you handle Pokemon not on
a handheld is it a kiddy well that's the
thing if I'm sure the switch is perfect
it's a handheld this which is a terrible
home console it is the best handheld
device ever yeah so I'm gonna play it as
a handheld game sometimes at home
Nintendo has this interesting strategy
right now where they've they give you a
little and then like their strategy
isn't to deliver a ton at launch they
want to trickle things out throughout
the year and give you a little bit at a
time to make the switch worth it right
well it's also hard for them to have
like seven games at once since they're
the only people making games for it yeah
well I mean that you know you have FIFA
which is coming and that that'll be fun
I guess if you're in a soccer like don't
don't write that off stop we're in
America Craig let's not worry about
soccer but but Nintendo itself has this
like strategy of kind of dangling the
carrot out in front of you to where it's
like hey we're gonna win out this it's
coming next year and you go oh yeah my
switch is worth it you know and then
they go okay and Metroid's coming soon
okay
and guess what Odyssey is coming sooner
and it's just kind of putting the carrot
out just a little bit further so to
extend your life just a little bit
longer for it it's just an interesting
one thing I am sad that didn't come from
that leaked list to the fake games which
was somewhat accurate there was supposed
to be another Mario Mario Party 11 on
there oh yeah I was sad we didn't see
any of that that was hoping for that
that would have been cool yeah we could
have taken credit for bringing it back
too so we got about another 12 minutes
or so before we wrap up in the show
floor closes today which makes me so sad
yes dad are you guys have fun at e3
today was it fun how many others looked
your question how many oh I see the
yellow yeah us an agile pretty much
everybody bond with everybody yeah what
you guys is this your first e3 coming
did y'all y'all like it y'all think it's
pretty cool how long did you all spend
playing versus standing in line
oh yeah rather than I'd answer did you
guys find it worth your money coming out
really just being here being part of it
interesting just you know we're gonna be
starting the game attack game Expo next
year for $200 a ticket as well I feel
it's far and there won't be any
developers there no it'll just be that a
lot is game no one's ever heard of
behind a curtain in a line that never
finishes perfect clean they're like I
waited all day but I didn't get in they
said it was great though so this is uh
it's funny cuz this is Sam's first e3
yeah I never gotta come before but
you've been in the industry for seven
years seven seven years yes I'm actually
being I've been at the office uploading
videos the last seven years yes I never
got to come until now it'll read oh not
just this let you guys know if your
dream job is to work in the industry you
can get that dream job and then wait
seven more years to go to the biggest
event that you probably wanted to go to
when the public in in or to like I could
have just shown up here we go yeah it's
pretty good like I mean it's cool I
don't like lines much so you know that's
a bit of a bummer but I like looking at
stuff and there's a lot of stuff to look
at that I'll say the dragon over there
yeah like I just walked in I was like oh
stuff yeah then I get out without I'm
happy that's my whole experience people
can ask how was it I was like I saw
things good my eyes were stimulated done
was did you play anything nah man I'm
good I see on screen I know it's like I
can't were the last time I seen two game
on screen I mean like huh I bet I know
how that works in the night was
surprised by it it's always accurate
you're like yeah first-person shooter
played that before I bet it'll be good
you're right Peggy it's not it's not
like they were gonna pull a fast one and
like this Metroid's gonna come out and
play like call of duty and we're gonna
be like what like it's not gonna happen
it's a 2d we we're good we're great
they're a couple new things
good wouldn't that be the biggest
shocker of all is is that they they
announced Call of Duty Metroid donut up
in World War two for some reason Metroid
Prime the screen comes on fifty thousand
people used to live here
you friggin awful Oh okay so uh bowling
this year ii III on the floor huh you
have any any lasting memories from this
this III from this III yeah this right
here is probably open here five hours
how can you make memories yeah is it say
there's what there's a lot to see a lot
to do you know man I tell you what no it
was it's it's busy there's a lot of
people here and I hope you guys I hope
you guys get get get to play this is
this is my eleventh III and I see oh oh
oh you this guy special y'all as
somebody who's been there for a decade
know so I've seen like the I've seen the
the reason I've seen the how the peaks
of like the absolute most people can be
in and then the lows of being in an
airplane hangar right there's more
people here than I've ever seen it to
III and it's insane I don't know if
that's a whoo I don't know it's because
because I think it affects you guys like
then that you guys don't have an
opportunity to play everything you guys
wanted to play which you know that I I
think there's definitely gonna be some
give-and-take so be interesting to see
if the key is if you want some advice in
line waiting
the key is pick exactly what you want to
play and don't don't second-guess
yourself because if you want to come to
e3 and you and you know you want to play
whatever it is you want to play destiny
to if you want to play if you want play
spider-man get in that spider-man line
and play it and just stick to the line
and get it done so you don't have any
regrets because I I you may not get
another chance to come so you know you
can say I played that at e3 the
otherwise make sure and see everything
yeah look around like yeah man that
Monster Hunter dragon and these
companies are spending at millions of
dollars to imbue yeah the Wolfman so
kind little like cafe diner thing oh
yeah yeah it does see the the
Wolfenstein thing like if you don't get
to play any games it's okay it's okay
don't sweat it it's appreciate
you know it being open to the public I
imagine you know my best friend he you
know he's always said someday I'm gonna
go to e3 and and you know I've been like
it's a lot of lines and he's like I
don't care just want to go so just
appreciate everything soak it all in and
try to have a good time
appreciate GameSpot for coming out and
doing stuff like this and bringing you O
great coverage and letting us come to
you letting us suckers be on a stage and
talk to you guys I know it's good you
would have told kid me that I got to do
this he would've been ecstatic I'm
really not you're lying no I I am from I
am from the backwoods of East Texas like
4,000 people in my town and I and I I
saw Brandon Jones who was up here
earlier on game trailers and like I
never thought I would I would do
anything like this so you can do it too
yeah you can do it too you can do it too
do it do what move tomorrow tomorrow
man oh man you're gonna watch game it's
actually you got a joke just a bad Total
Recall yes bad total Rica I got it okay
oh it just wasn't funny yeah okay so uh
we have just couple minutes left overall
thoughts games that you're excited for
last chance to put a cherry on
everything and feel good about things
I'm excited I'm gonna play the hell out
of Crash Bandicoot you can watch that
game attack June 30th 11:00 am excited
about days gone I'm really excited to
see what monster hunter world yell about
oh yeah I wanted to play like a
high-fidelity monster forever and
honestly I'm really interesting Call of
Duty World War 2 go ahead and go ahead
and boo that's fine but uh but like I'm
really excited to see if that changes
the multiplayer formula so it won't yeah
he'll still be fun yeah um Sam what you
excited for I'm right there with monster
hunter world looks amazing I'm super
excited I'm really curious about anthem
it just looks like it might be great key
word might there um yeah that's I mean
those are the two big hitters for me
Ron oh yeah all you got there's a lot of
other stuff here like I think why I got
a lot of faith in Wolfenstein 2 to be
very solid and great but I'm not curious
about it because I'm just like yeah I'll
patiently wait and play that yeah I'm
good they're like you know I think I
know what I'm getting and I'm happy to
get it Metro's the same situation looks
awesome I want another Metro game
wonderful it's come just just into it
yeah it's what about you Craig things
I'm excited for data for 100% yeah I'm
excited for see of Thieves
100% on that and I'm excited for
anything Nintendo makes cuz everything
in genomics is the best that's why that
that that's that's where I'm at right
now
hey shut off soon I just want to say one
more thing about the lines find find the
smaller games at the big company boots
like PlayStation you know they've got
Call of Duty and all that set up like
find the smaller games like go go to the
smaller devs and talk to them and listen
to how excited they are about the games
and then you'll get the experience of
playing something at e3 and
communicating with devs it's really
awesome like we saw we saw Wilson here
hey Holly better watching this game
three and a half years reading ahead how
long have you known about this game a
couple months you know it's like if
these things there's so many projects
that are happening that we won't hear
about for you know two years from now
and that are really miserable like
there's awesome games out there that are
on the floor that you're not hearing
about just because they get they get
buried by the big stories that you're
really paying it to do so check out the
smaller games too so we got a couple
minutes left and I this is the audience
interaction part of the show uh-oh where
I uh there's always the big question
we're Tuesday's the first day of e3 and
it's always good to uh it think the
question is always like who won e3 don't
do that oh we're doing it because
because we are one day in there's not
going to be any more announcements and
this the question everybody wants to
know right that's the Internet right we
were you guys care about who won III see
like that guy that guys that give the
knowing nod yeah absolutely that's right
hell yeah give me that thumb
this one's talking about that did he say
no what's that the gamers we have
reasons but really who would it best see
you it's a crap in Burleigh who is best
well let's find out okay so we're
getting we're gonna go from press
conference to press conference the big
three okay because he a there you know
they're all developers even though
Ubisoft at the best presser of the
weekend yeah not gonna count it
no no we're just gonna go the big three
company man man mitt sale what no no I'm
just saying it would be soft wasn't that
good they were okay but they had a bit
of dance number that throws him down a
peg dance summer throw it up I'm out on
I'm asleep every year it's not a staple
I like this but you want me to put a
staple in your arm you're not gonna
enjoy it that's how it's terrible it's
like you know it's the time for sever
you go back go back to your audience
interaction I don't hate just answers
like okay so by applause we're gonna go
from in order of the press conference
that appeared so who thinks Microsoft
with the Xbox 1x and all their fun and
all their fun stuff
one III all right that was very
underwhelming
yeah no one liked him how many all felt
PlayStation 1 1 III
are you are you encouraging are you
clapping huh we just believe PlayStation
1 ok how many all believe Nintendo 1 III
Wow
interesting ok they did more than just
show a name of a game on screen yeah
yeah I'm just saying I don't know I
thought it was interesting I thought it
would be the other way but not everybody
thought spider-man was a QTE trash pit
like I did apparently so majority of the
game isn't yeah I'm totally nerdy
luckily make a spectacle but alright
that is all the time we have today thank
you guys so much Lauren big round of
applause for Laura natal day over there
that's great she was running around and
I'm scared that we squeeze stressed her
out really bad but she's the best he
said some things I strike ok but yeah
thanks so much for forgetting spot for
having us out and and lending us the
stage to do stupid things and talk to
you guys for an hour and a half it was
awesome round applause you guys for
coming out hanging out uh and yes indeed
the gamers truly won yes yes are you
guys have a great day thanks so much
coming to e3
see you guys and make sure you go
subscribe to game attack have a great
day guys thank you